[Music]
a satirical slap in heinlein's face a
love triangle that doesn't exist and a
seriously gutting happy ending maybe the
bugs were the real heroes after all most
filmmakers take on book adaptations
because they enjoy the source material
that wasn't the case for Paul verhoven
when he agreed to direct Starship
Troopers he interpreted Robert
heinlein's novel as ideologically
fascist and pro-war and since fairhoven
grew up in Nazi occupied Holland during
World War II it's understandable why he
lambasts these ideas in an interview
with Digital Spy the director explained
that he wanted to make a movie about a
fascist Utopia where citizens aren't
aware of what was really going on in the
film Casper Van Dean's Johnny Rico and
his mobile infantry unit are happy to
risk their lives on the battlefield
despite how they're viewed by their
higher ups fresh meat for the grinder eh
while Starship Troopers is mostly a
cautionary tale about totalitarianism
the movie boasts a cast of likable
characters who are easy to root for if
you overlook their enjoyment of blasting
through bugs and how they blindly follow
a questionable regime the heroes are
regular people this drives home the idea
that everyday folks easily becomes
spokes in the wheel of an authoritarian
state if they don't hold their leaders
accountable
Starship Troopers isn't exactly subtle
in how it skewers fascism the film is
littered with Nazi imagery and nods to
German propaganda films from World War
II the opening shot was pinched from
Lenny riefenstahl's Infamous propaganda
film Triumph of the will and the
officers uniforms are reminiscent of the
Nazi SS and gestapo while these visuals
were included to get the film's point
across to the audience verhoven's crew
also appreciated the aesthetic appeal of
the uniforms according to an interview
with Entertainment Weekly screenwriter
Ed newmeyer claimed Germans made the
best looking stuff this appealed to the
film's art directors and costume
designers with verhoven adding that the
goal was to deconstruct propaganda films
giving the viewers some food for thought
regarding the bigger issues berhoven
said I tried to seduce the audience to
join Starship Troopers Society but then
ask what are you really joining up for
Hollywood likes a good romance story
especially if it involves a love
triangle increasing drama and conflict
between the characters Starship Troopers
was going to down that route until test
audiences reacted poorly to the subplot
where Denise Richards Carmen couldn't
decide if she wanted to be with Rico or
Patrick Muldoon's Xander barcolo while a
love triangle is teased with Rico often
acting jealous Starship Troopers is more
interested in Carmen's personal
qualities than her love life she's
depicted as a smart career-driven pilot
who's good at her job and doesn't need
to be romantically involved with anyone
to be interesting I think I'm gonna go
career
I want to command
ship of my own and you know according to
the guardian Richards described Carmen
as a strong woman and a great role model
noting that the lack of a romantic
resolution for her character was the
best decision Young Love is messy and
everyone gets their heart broken at some
point if there's any message about love
inside Starship Troopers besides
fascists loving War it's that there's no
such thing as living happily ever after
we all clearly noticed the room full of
naked people regardless of what age we
saw this movie but we may not have
appreciated the subtext until later
there's an argument to be made that the
co-ed shower scene in Starship Troopers
isn't necessary designed to incite
thirst and nothing more let's not forget
that verhoven directed Basic Instinct
and Showgirls immediately prior to this
film however this scene isn't as
gratuitous as it might first appear the
main group of recruits discussed their
reasons for enlisting in the military
one of them wants to escape the farm
life and see the universe and another
has political aspirations the scene
highlights the camaraderie between the
Troopers and at no point do they
showcase any physical desire toward each
other this this scene reinforces the
idea that all of the soldiers are
regarded as equals quite Progressive for
a fascist military-industrial complex
Starship Troopers is considered so
refreshing in its portrayal of gender
politics it passes the bechdel test
several times over
Starship Troopers has a nearly all-white
main cast and most of them are good
looking but the movie's lack of
diversity was certainly intentional
verhoven spoke directly to the idea when
talking about casting van Deen as Rico
Mark Wahlberg and Matt Damon auditioned
but I was looking for the Prototype of
blonde white and arrogant and Casper Van
Deen was so close to the images I
remembered from Lenny riefenstyle's
films that said it's worth noting that
there's more diversity in the original
novel The book's lead character is a
Filipino man named Juan while this
aspect was overlooked for artistic
reasons it still makes Starship Troopers
one of the many Hollywood Blockbusters
to have whitewashed people of color from
the original Source material at the same
time commenting on fascism wasn't the
only reason for casting 90s heartthrobs
like van Deen Richards Neil Patrick
Harris and Jake Busey in the main roles
according to screen slate verhoven
wanted actors who looked wholesome
innocent and classically beautiful
further enhancing the notion that war
makes good people do rotten things while
it can be argued that adding more
diversity could have similarly
Illustrated this point Point there's no
denying that Starship Troopers has clear
intentions
let's do something
how many series and I
secret that Starship Troopers is a
subversive movie it was verhoven's
intention from the very beginning to
satirize both the original pro-war novel
as well as the increasingly
imperialistic nature of the United
States to that end the movie made some
key changes from the book that seek to
show how evil the military-run
government really is underneath one of
the biggest examples of this is the
Buenos Aires plot line which can easily
be taken at face value until you
re-watch it as an adult the mysterious
enemy race of aliens known as the
arachnids are seemingly capable of
hurling asteroids across vast distances
of space to attack human targets so when
an asteroid decimates the Earth City of
Buenos Aires where Rico's parents live
it sets Humanity on a bloodthirsty Path
of Revenge against the aliens the only
good part is bug
yet the filmmakers hint at more going on
with this event than the characters
would make it seem many have speculated
that the destruction of Buenos Aires was
a false flag attack by the human
government to justify an invasion of the
arachnid Homeworld clendathu the only
information about the arachnids
capability to send asteroids towards
Earth comes from the fascist military
government which casts doubt on The
credibility of their claims
Humanity's militaristic Society does
everything it can to paint the arachnids
as the most heartless creatures
imaginable multiple propaganda scenes
exist solely to degrade devalue and
disrespect the alien foe as part of
Humanity's war effort but how true are
the claims fans know that verhoven
intentionally made the film seem like a
piece of propaganda portraying a utopian
fascist society that to audiences in
1997 would look absurdly nightmarish
because of the satirical nature and
propagandistic tone it's no surprise
that the characters of the film are so
merciless to their enemies in one scene
we see children on Earth squishing
real-life cockroaches this is framed as
a patriot act for the war effort
symbolizing Humanity crushing the
arachnids but it becomes clear that the
bugs are largely misunderstood creatures
forced into fighting a defensive war
against aggressive human colonization
the end of Starship Troopers shows just
how victimized the bugs actually are
after capturing the massive brain bug
Carl Jenkins played by Neil Patrick
Harris is able to feel its emotions and
relay them to the army of Troopers it's
afraid
it's a Fray
while the end of the movie features all
the explosive action that fans enjoy the
first half of Starship Troopers focuses
on how these attractive young humans are
trained for war Rico along with his
friends Carmen Carl and dizzy are all
taught by a roster of intimidating
instructors who have experienced combat
firsthand on first viewing these scenes
are overshadowed by the love rectangle
between Rico dizzy Carmen and Xander but
it isn't until revisiting Starship
Troopers as an adult that the depressing
nature of the film's teacher student
Dynamic becomes apparent the instructors
fought against the arachnids suffering
horrific physical disfigurements in
combat Michael Ironsides John rocheck is
missing an arm and the biology teacher
played by Rue McClanahan is blind and
heavily scarred these physical
conditions foreshadow the fates of many
students who will go off to war
Starship Troopers seems to have a happy
ending with their Heroes defeating their
enemies and going off to successful
military careers but thanks to the
film's satirical Edge this excitement
feels Hollow Rico's character Arc
throughout the film shows us just how
sad of an ending this really is at the
start Rico is a conflicted character who
is unsure of his place in the military
Machinery he joins the mobile infantry
but not out of any sense of patriotic
duty while it's true that his military
service will guarantee him citizenship
his desire to continue a romantic
relationship with Carmen is what draws
him into the war he shows compassion and
conscientiousness during his training as
well as deep regret when he directly
contributes to the death of a fellow
Soldier during an exercise gone wrong
it's not until the invasion of clendathu
after his parents are killed in the
Buenos Aires attack that Rico
drastically changes into a killing
machine Starship Troopers ends with an
in-universe propaganda video encouraging
new recruits to join the military so
they can be heroes like Rico come on you
for
a man as initially open-minded as Rico
this is an unhappy ending he is now
truly just a cog in the war machine
[Music]